SPEAKER 1: Thanks, everyone,
for coming to this event.
This is a Talks at Google
event in partnership
with [INAUDIBLE].
And we are thrilled to
have the national tour
cast of "Hamilton" here.
[APPLAUSE]
So a little background on how
"Hamilton, an American Musical"
came to be.
It started in 2004,
when a historian
named Ron Chernow actually
published a biography
of Alexander Hamilton.
There hadn't really
been many biographies
written about him, at least
in the previous few decades.
And in this biography,
it talks about Hamilton
from his immigration
to the United
States from the
Caribbean as an orphan,
his joining the
American Revolution,
and ultimately becoming
one of the founding fathers
of our country.
And Lin-Manuel Miranda,
who was previously
doing "In the Heights"
at that time--
he was actually on vacation,
and was reading the book.
And the themes of the
book stuck with him,
and he really wanted to tell
this story to more people,
because it's a great story.
And he wrapped that into a more
modern retelling, which started
out as a mixtape, actually.
And you can look
it up on YouTube,
when he originally played
this for the Obamas,
actually, in the White House.
And from the mix tape, it
went off Broadway in 2015,
then eventually went onto
Broadway later that year.
The Chicago company
started in 2016.
And then 2017 kicked
off the Angelica tour,
which is the national United
States tour of the play.
And we are thrilled to be here.
So it started in San Francisco.
We've been lucky to have them
here for about five months so
far, at the SHN.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
It's still here
for another week.
If you haven't seen it yet--
I mean, hopefully most people
have been able to see it.
But there's about another
week of performances, right?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Week and a half.
SPEAKER 1: So definitely see
it before then, and if not,
it's going to LA next, and
that's close plane ride.
So without further ado,
let's welcome Ruben Carbajal
and Ryan Alvarado.
[APPLAUSE]
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: So I was wondering
if you guys could kick it
off just talking a little
bit about the characters
that you play.
Some people in the audience
might have seen the show,
some might not have.
But a little bit about the
character or characters
that you guys play in the show.
And then give us a little
fun fact about yourselves
if you have one.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: OK.
Oh, cool.
Hi, everyone, thank you
so much for having us.
It's an honor to be here,
and to see all of you here.
It's awesome.
My name is Ruben J. Carbajal.
I play two roles in "Hamilton."
I play John Laurens
and Philip Hamilton.
So in act one I get to
play John Laurens, who
was a Revolutionary War hero.
And in the world of the play,
he's Hamilton's best friend.
I'd say he's his best one.
[LAUGHTER]
So and then in--
Some may argue.
And then in act two, I get
to play Hamilton's son,
Philip Hamilton, his first son.
Yeah, fun fact.
Oh, man, you told me to
think about it, and I forgot.
SPEAKER 1: Interesting or fun.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I've been
dancing Mexican folk dancing
since I was three years old.
AUDIENCE: Whoo-hoo!
RYAN ALVARADO: What?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: That's why
these things are good.
Stuff like that comes out.
RYAN ALVARADO: I don't have
anything as cool as that.
My goodness.
I'm Ryan Alvarado.
I'm a principal standby in the
Angelica company of "Hamilton."
I'm responsible for covering
Alexander Hamilton, Aaron
Burr, King George III.
Yeah, that's what I do.
SPEAKER 1: One person
who runs three parts.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah, and
slightly less interesting--
yeah, I was going to say
that I was born in the Bronx.
I'm Puerto Rican.
My parents are from Puerto Rico.
[APPLAUSE]
Hey, hola.
And wow, I did not grow
up Mexican folk dancing,
but I wish I did.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I'm
sorry, that's the first thing
I thought of.
RYAN ALVARADO: No, yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
I didn't mean to--
RYAN ALVARADO: And I'm
an avid hip hop fan.
I enjoy-- obviously.
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah.
Hi.
[LAUGHTER]
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
You have a dog.
RYAN ALVARADO: I do have a dog.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: That's
really interesting.
RYAN ALVARADO: I have a dog.
SPEAKER 1: Is the
dog on tour with you?
RYAN ALVARADO: She is.
She is, yes.
She's sick at the
moment, I know.
[GROANS]
I was fielding some texts.
But yeah, she's OK.
She's OK.
SPEAKER 1: First
question for you guys.
As I mentioned, "Hamilton"
premiered in 2015 on Broadway,
and made this huge
cultural splash back then.
I'm interested in hearing
what your guy's exposure was
to the play when
it first came out,
when you weren't part of it.
And then how was stepping into
those roles, and those shoes,
of the likes of Anthony Ramos,
and Jonathan Groff, and such?
Did you have any
contact with them?
How did you train
up on those roles?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Well, I
first heard about the show
when it was still a glimmer
of a show, when it was still
the "Hamilton Mixtape."
I had been a huge fan of
Lin-Manuel Miranda's work.
And growing up, I became very
invested in his musical "In
the Heights."
I got to see it at the Pantages
with Lin starring in it, which
was awesome and inspiring.
I became obsessed with his
work, and with musical theater
in general because of
that show, and I just
started Googling everything
I knew about him.
[LAUGHTER]
And this-- oh, Goo--
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: It's nice when
it's unintentional, right?
[LAUGHTER]
It's become such a
big part of my life.
SPEAKER 1: That's
cool, that's cool.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Thank you all.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh my gosh.
I didn't get paid
for that, I promise.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah.
I just was on the
computer, and I
came across this video of him
doing this thing at the White
House.
And I was like, what is that?
Like, a rap about Alexander
Hamilton-- people laughed.
I mean, if the way he
introduced it was he said,
I think something about somebody
who embodied hip hop for him,
and he said it was
Alexander Hamilton.
And so I got very
interested in that.
And then it kind of was
quiet for a little bit,
because they were
still working on it.
And then I knew
that it was going
to be off-Broadway in New York,
so I tried to get tickets.
And I was in New York
a couple of times,
and it just didn't work out.
And then it went to Broadway.
And then they were
like, oh, we're
also going to do a Chicago
production and a national tour.
So I was like, well,
how do I audition?
How do I do I get into it?
So yeah.
I mean, when I saw that
the musical was going
to be what it is, which is
the story of America then told
as American now, with people
of color in these roles,
I was like, I think
I fit right in.
I mean, looks-wise, I think so.
I'm a Mexican-American,
first generation.
So I was like, this
is perfect, and this
is such an amazing story.
And I think that with the cast
recording coming out shortly
after that, I just
became obsessed.
It was just like always
playing, I knew all the words
within the first month.
And yeah, I didn't actually get
to see it until late last year,
because it was so dang
hard to get a ticket.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Even the
inside people, wow.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah, yeah.
I was in and out of
auditions last year,
and to finally get
that call that I
was going to be a part of the
show that I have looked up to,
and the show that has affected
the lives of so many people--
it was an honor.
And so getting to talk with
some of the original cast--
I got to meet Chris
Jackson, who played
George Washington in
the original company,
and who has worked
with Lin dating back
to "In the Heights."
And speaking with him and what
he had to say about the show,
and how important it is,
and how lucky we are to--
I want to say be
alive right now, but--
[LAUGHTER]
How lucky we are to be this
close to something so powerful.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah, yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
That just gave me
all the inspiration I
needed to go and conquer
what I set out to do.
But yeah, that's
been sort of my story
with the show in a nutshell.
I'll let Ryan share his.
RYAN ALVARADO: Oh, mine
is actually very similar.
My introduction to Lin's world
was through "In the Heights."
I was fortunate enough to do
that work a couple of times.
And it's one of those
things where yeah, it's
modern tellings
of a great story.
"In the Heights" is
telling the Latin story,
which I connect to it.
I relate it to everything
that I saw on stage.
And it was a great
honor and a privilege
and a pleasure to
perform in the show.
Once you're in them, one
thing that Lin does--
and if you've seen the show--
no matter what the
story, there's always
a great heart at the core.
It's really about people.
It's really about connections.
And the work facilitates that.
So it's always called me.
I think it's called
most of us that
have made it to do
the work, and be
in this production of "Hamilton"
in some way or another.
That's what I saw when
I was fortunate enough
to see the original Broadway
company before there was even
a cast recording.
And so I definitely--
I like to know the words.
I'm sure many of you
were told or warned
that a lot of information is
about to be thrown at you.
Maybe you want to listen
to this cast recording,
and get a head start on it.
I didn't even have the option,
but I did want to see it.
So I saw it, I was
moved, I was thrown.
It was a very big moment in
my artistic life, and growing.
And similar, yeah, it
just kind of called to me,
and I saw my spot.
And I could taste it, you
know, and similar, and the work
began.
The cast recording came out
not too long after I saw it,
and I just started
like dedicating myself
to the distance between
me now and me then,
in terms of what I needed to do
to really maximize my chances
at getting this opportunity.
So that was my way in,
and that's my connection.
And as I do it now,
that's the greatest part,
is getting to
connect with people.
And we do this work, and
people love it, and it's great.
But the thing that
I take from it
is the camaraderie,
the family that we
built through this
work, and then
the connection of the
people that see it
and understanding like
what it does for them.
And that in turn does
even more for us,
to know that you can
be in the audience,
and you're going to
have that same moment
that I had when I saw it.
But now, I get to be
part of the gift givers.
And that's a blessing
in and of itself.
It's a constant reminder,
just being in rooms like this.
And I'm constantly grateful.
We all are.
We're always thanking our lucky
stars together in big groups.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Always.
RYAN ALVARADO: You know.
But yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Cool.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
Ruben, you touched a
little bit on the actual
trying out process.
I'm interested.
I don't think many of us in
this room have done theater.
And what all entails of
trying out for a part?
Like, how do you apply?
Do you send a resume somewhere?
Like, how do you
get from that to--
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
Like, we do coding
interviews and stuff here.
RYAN ALVARADO: It's a lot
like the "Hunger Games."
SPEAKER 1: "Hunger Games," OK.
What was it like for you guys
going through the process
of being on the outside, and
then going through this "Hunger
Games"-likesque process of
becoming part of the show?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Yeah, step one
was just to find out where and
when the audition was actually
going to be held.
I have an awesome
representation.
So my agency--
I got to contact
them and say, hey,
this is what I'm interested in.
If there's any way that I
can audition for this show
I would love it, because
it's what I want to do.
I think that me along
with everybody in SoCal
had the same idea, because those
agent appointments were booked.
They were like, we tried.
There's just no room.
SPEAKER 1: So they
had regional tryouts?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah,
I auditioned in LA.
I know they had some
in Dallas, and I
think Atlanta maybe had some.
But yeah, they were
all over the country.
For me, looking at that, I
was like this is overwhelming.
There's so many people that
are going to go audition.
Because I wasn't able to
get an initial appointment,
I went to the open call.
So it's just like we
were at United Methodist
Church in Hollywood.
The line was snaking through
this humongous parking lot.
I think in total, it was about
700 to 1,000 people showed up.
I was saying earlier,
it kind of felt
like "American
Idol." it was like--
[LAUGHTER]
I went into the room,
and they were like, OK,
the audition was supposed
to be about 30 seconds
of a nonmusical theater song.
So immediately I'm like, OK,
well "Hamilton" is hip hop,
it's rap, there's some
singing involved too.
So let me think
outside of the box,
because a lot of the
times, I'm auditioning
with musical theater pieces.
So I pick my song, and I sang
"Billionaire," by Bruno Mars.
And did like some of
the rap and stuff.
So I was feeling myself,
and I was like, all right,
we're going--
[LAUGHTER]
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Let's get it.
I went and did my thing.
And then I went from
one room to the next,
and they were like,
here's this red ticket.
So I'm like, this
is "American Idol."
[LAUGHTER]
If not--
RYAN ALVARADO: Or the
ticket's a counter.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I'm like,
being punked right now.
So that room led me to
a callback the next day.
And then after that,
it was about two weeks,
and I got invited to go to a
callback in New York and sing.
So this whole time, I just been
singing for the casting people,
Telsey, who did the casting.
So not even any of
the creative team.
But when I went
to New York, I got
to sing for Alex Lacamoire who
did the orchestrations and part
of the writing for the show.
And he's a genius, and it's
been awesome to work with him.
But sang for him, and
then got invited back
to sing for him
and Tommy Kail, who
is the director of
"Hamilton," and also
directed "In the Heights."
Alex Lacamoire also
did orchestrations
for "In the Heights."
So they've all worked
together, so they know exactly
what they're looking for.
So just to be in that room, I
knew that I had made somewhat
of a good impression.
SPEAKER 1: At that
point, did you
know who you were going
to be trying out for?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yes.
After that, my agent sort of
handled all that information
that they would pass on, and be
like, OK, like Alex Lacamoire's
going to be in the room today.
And then the next time, it was
OK, Alex Lacamoire, Tommy Kail.
And then I got invited to the
final callbacks in New York.
I think I was in New York for
about 10 days, auditioning,
and meetings, and
dance calls, which--
dance isn't my strong suit.
So I was nervous, like that was
the most nerve-wracking part
for me.
And I was dancing for
Andy Blankenbuehler, who
did the original choreography.
And then my final audition, they
had told me-- they were like,
the creative team
will be in the room.
Some of the producers
And it should be
about 15 minutes.
I'm like, OK.
So I prepared all my material.
By this time, they
had given me my packet
of material for the roles
that I was auditioning for.
And then the funny thing
was, the whole time, I
was thinking like OK,
Lin-Manuel might be in the room.
I'll just have to
prep myself for it.
It'll be fine.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just like, deep breaths.
Somebody at the audition
will tell me, oh yeah,
Lin's in the room, so
just like, you know.
So I was prepping that whole
time to just play it cool.
And then I was waiting
outside of the audition room,
and I'm just praying, and
also taking deep breaths,
and trying to hold
my breakfast down.
And somebody in the room
walked out and, they were like,
is he here yet?
And they were like, oh no, I
think he's just running late.
So I'm like, oh,
they must be talking
about somebody auditioning.
And then the door opens,
and I see Lin-Manuel just
stroll into the audition room.
And I was like--
[LAUGHTER]
All my preparation just
went out the window.
But I was like, you know what?
I can't let this
affect my audition.
It actually made me more excited
to audition, because I'm like,
this is the man.
This is his role,
this is his musical,
and now I get to
show him what I got.
So that was an experience
I'll never forget.
And I am sure that that helped
me to get to where I am today.
Because still, after
that, it was a few months,
had three more auditions,
and finally booked the show.
So yeah, I mean, it was--
SPEAKER 1: That's
a long journey.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah, yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: From when
I first auditioned to opening
night, it was about a year.
SPEAKER 1: So were you working
on something else at the time?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Yeah, auditioning, and I
did a guest star on
a TV show last year,
which was really fun, and
it kind of kept me busy.
And with a show like
"Hamilton," there
are more productions opening up.
So they're always
looking for people.
But something that I
just had to tell myself
was maybe not at this moment.
So every time I came
out of an audition room,
and I felt like I gave
it my all, I said,
OK, well, I did
what I had to do.
Now it's up to powers beyond me.
So God granted me
with the opportunity
that I'm blessed with.
And yeah, I'm lucky to be
here only a year later.
I mean, I say a year, but
if I really think about it,
it's a short amount of time
to be where I wanted to be.
So yeah.
RYAN ALVARADO: The
process was similar-ish.
It was the same thing.
It was definitely long.
I think all said and done,
from first audition to getting
the phone call was about maybe
like five or six months for me.
I was lucky enough that my
first audition, Alex Lacamoire
happened to be in the room.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Nice.
RYAN ALVARADO: I don't
know why, but he was there.
[LAUGHTER]
And the funny thing is
that, not similar to Ruben,
I don't have representation.
Still to this day, I
don't have a manager,
I just don't have an agent.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyone looking to sign--
no.
SPEAKER 1: Casting
out a call now.
RYAN ALVARADO:
Yeah, so I didn't.
So much of it was just--
not more on me, but I
kept my head in the game,
eyes on the prize,
that kind of thing.
I felt like that audition
went well, the very first one.
But not having an
agent or manager
bridging the gap for
me, and figuring out
when that next audition was--
I believe that I had a callback
coming, but I didn't know.
So I just kept
going to auditions.
SPEAKER 1: Did they
tell you what progress
you were towards the end goal?
RYAN ALVARADO: No, no.
And I didn't care.
I didn't care at the time.
I just kept going.
I felt like the time was
now, and I just felt it.
So I kept going,
to the point that--
they kept seeing me,
and then eventually, I
think that they were
just like, it's coming.
And then they started--
they do this thing where they
type you in, and type you out.
And we're types for this show.
I've been typed in before.
And all of a sudden, I was
just getting typed out.
So I was like, this isn't
over, this isn't over.
But then my callback came,
and then that process started.
And it was slow.
And again, yeah, it's
like this room is going
to have two casting associates.
One is going to have
three casting associates.
Now we have the head of casting.
And then I did a work session
with the associate director,
and the associate music
director from Broadway.
And then that led into doing
another session with Lac
and Tommy, who are our musical
director and director proper,
to then the room with
all the producers.
I actually never was
never in a room with Lin.
But yeah, pretty much everyone
but, I would assume, yeah.
Yeah, and then I found
out around Thanksgiving.
I sank like, six floors
through my apartment building.
[LAUGHTER]
And then yeah, and
the rest is history.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, if you
guys haven't already seen,
we have another guest
joining us here.
[LAUGHTER]
Put your hands together.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN ALVARADO: Whoo-whoo.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Hi, guys.
Hi.
RYAN ALVARADO: Hey.
SPEAKER 1: Solea Pfeiffer.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Hi.
SPEAKER 1: So Solea, we'll
catch you up a little bit.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: OK.
SPEAKER 1: Can you just tell
us your role in the play,
just a little bit of a
description of who you play?
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: And then if you have
one, a fun fact about yourself,
fun or interesting fact.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: OK,
I'm Solea Pfeiffer.
I play Eliza Hamilton, I am
wife to him, mother to him.
SPEAKER 1: You got
the whole family.
[LAUGHTER]
SOLEA PFEIFFER: At any
given day of this week.
And my fun fact--
I've got two fun facts.
I was born in Zimbabwe,
which is always my go to.
People are always like, oh.
And so that's my fun fact.
And I have a really
weird irrational fear
of Wallace and Gromit.
So that's my other one.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Stop
motion animation.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah.
Can't explain it.
Great.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you
so much for joining us.
OK, so let's go into
the next question.
So you guys have been in the Bay
Area for about five months now.
You've met a lot of fans here.
You've seen what the
theater scene's like.
I think a lot of
the sports teams
and stuff have
reached to you guys.
You've had some
opportunities there.
I was wondering what your
thoughts are of the Bay Area
compared to other places
that you've performed before.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, you can
be blunt about it.
It's definitely
not Broadway, but I
think there is some
sort of a scene here.
So I just wanted to--
[LAUGHTER]
I just want to hear
what you guys think
the fans have been like, and
the Bay Area has been like.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
You can start.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Me?
I'll start?
OK.
I think I couldn't
think of a better city
to start this tour in, really.
What Tommy would always say as
we were starting this process
was that now once this
show and this piece
leaves New York City, instead
of people coming to New York,
and flying from all over to
come to New York to see it,
we are going to your home.
And there's something really
special about having arrived
here, and being able to
bring it to the city,
as opposed to the
city coming to us.
And these crowds have
been insane, you guys.
I feel like I've
been really spoiled.
I feel like our whole cast--
after any other show,
we're going to be like,
is anybody even out there?
[LAUGHTER]
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Because it
is so raucous every day.
I think our matinees are
usually the best ones,
and I think that's
kind of unique.
I think it's because
that's when the kids come.
And you will not find
a more dedicated fan
than a child fan of "Hamilton."
[LAUGHTER]
They are dedicated
and loyal to us.
They know us.
And it's amazing.
And I think--
I mean, I'm excited
to see what it's
like when we bring the show to a
city that's maybe a little less
woke, if that makes sense.
[LAUGHTER]
You know what I mean?
[APPLAUSE]
San Francisco-- everyone
here knows what's up,
and that's an amazing thing.
And we can always count
on a huge, huge applause
after the line,
immigrants, we get
the job done, without
fail, every single show,
and that's so amazing.
But there are other
cities in the country
that maybe don't feel that way.
And so right now, it
feels like a celebration,
and that's amazing.
And I couldn't think
of a better way
to start this tour
than celebrating
what this show means.
But it's going to be exciting
to bring it to cities
where we are challenging
how people think too.
And I think that's one of
the most exciting things
about this show, is that
it kind of challenges
people's perceptions, and
raises their consciousness
a little bit.
And so I mean, yeah, like I
said, this is a woke city.
[LAUGHTER]
And yeah, so I'm glad
we started with people
who are ready to just
embrace this show,
and embrace us all so 100%.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Do you want to?
RYAN ALVARADO: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
You don't want
to say what you
like about the city?
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN ALVARADO: I am from
New York originally.
I'm an east coast kid.
I was born in the Bronx.
I've been to LA once
for like, five days.
So my experience on the
west coast is super limited.
But I was just saying
before we started
the talk, I welcome the change
of air, the change of pace.
I love it here.
It's something that you can
sense and feel as soon as you
get off the plane.
It's just the pace is different,
the people are different.
And it's just so open
minded, and these
are things that you just
feel it before we even
say hello to anyone, or someone
says hello to you, which is--
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Totally
RYAN ALVARADO: --so
against the New York norm.
[INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yes.
RYAN ALVARADO: You know?
Yeah, so it's been
really great to me
to just spend-- not
like a vacation.
Even though we're here for work,
really, we're here to live.
So to live in it, to submerge
in it, it's been great.
It's been great.
I was saying, the sun just
feels differently here, it
just shines a little brighter.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: It does.
RYAN ALVARADO: It's really,
really, cool, and just-- yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah.
RYAN ALVARADO: Amazing.
SPEAKER 1: If you
want to-- all right,
the next question is
of kind of like that.
[LAUGHTER]
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I like
the Bay, don't get me wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: So you guys
have done a lot of stuff
with the local community.
And one of the things that I
would like to hear a little bit
more about is the #EduHam.
I know it's been with a
lot of the local schools,
and being able to see the kids.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that
for people that aren't
familiar with the program?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Yeah, I actually
got to host one of #EduHam
days, which was so much fun.
What it is, is we reach
out to the high schools
that are around the area
in which "Hamilton" is in.
So in New York, they're
doing it for the schools
around that area.
In Chicago, they're
doing the same.
And now we've brought
it to San Francisco.
They've partnered with the
Gilder Lehrman Institute.
And they've created
a curriculum wherein
the culmination of that
curriculum is seeing our show.
And so big companies often
buy out the entire theater
for these kids.
And they end up only
paying $10 to see our show,
every single one of them.
So our matinee that
day is for them, only
them, and their chaperones.
But before that, we get
to witness something
that I have never
witnessed before.
And that's they get to do
original work based on what
they've learned on our stage.
And so they come up,
and they come up solo,
they come in groups
of three, more.
And they'll do a rap, and
the girl will be like,
I'm going to be playing Martha
Washington, and this is my rap.
And they'll do it, and it's
so historically accurate,
and just--
[LAUGHTER]
Wow.
RYAN ALVARADO:
Including the rapping.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Yeah, yeah It's
just you get to see the
creative side of these kids.
And I when I got to host,
I asked a couple of them--
I was like, oh my
gosh, so what shows,
what musicals have
you guys done?
And they're like,
we don't do that.
And I was like, oh.
But they're like,
but we might start.
I'm like, oh well,
that's awesome.
We're introducing
art and history,
and we're kind of changing
how these kids think,
and I think that's so special.
I want to have them kind of
see the experience of watching.
But it was-- oh, my gosh.
I just sat there, just
jaw to the ground, just--
SOLEA PFEIFFER: It's amazing.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Wow, like, these kids--
I think they're sophomores
and juniors in high school,
getting ready to go
off into the world.
And now they have
all this information
and this inspiration, so yeah.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah, I was on
the guest panel at the #EduHam
that Ruben moderated.
And it was quite
touching, actually.
These kids, they
really get up there.
And some of them, their
performing experience
is doing the same thing
that they just did,
but they did it in
their cafeteria,
or in their school auditorium.
You
It's a big bridge to get--
we have a Broadway stage out
at the Orpheum.
It can be intimidating,
and it's just 2,300
of their peers watching them.
And then they go, and they
do what they prepared,
and it's magnificent.
And it's just like, wow.
It reminds us how special
of what they are doing,
and how special of what the
opportunity that we're given.
And it's a unique
thing that we're
in something that can
connect history to art,
and really bridge
the gap, and get
these kids interested in
that subject, or in art.
It's twofold, and we're
just sitting there
in the center of it,
just like, wow, wow, wow.
Oh my goodness, wow.
And it's really cool.
To us-- we do the
show every day,
but that's like a real
treasure, a real treat
to just be in the
room to witness that.
I've always enjoyed it.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah.
The #EduHam days are always
my favorite days to perform.
Because the reactions
from the audience
are always completely
different than any other show.
You can always guarantee-- like,
kids love a kiss on a button.
When we get married, and we
kiss, and it all buttons up,
every time, they go ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
They love it.
And there's just different
reactions, so that's exciting.
But you also know that they
are taking in this information
differently than
other audiences.
And you can hear it in
the way that they react,
but also, seeing the
kids before they perform,
you can see their
hearts beating.
You're like, this
is a huge moment,
and one that feels like it
might change them forever.
It feels like it could
be their defining moment.
You'll see them-- sometimes they
might stutter over their words,
and the rest of the kids are
just there for them 100%,
and nothing fills our
hearts more than those days.
And yeah, connecting
history to art.
And then a lot of these
kids are from maybe more
of a disadvantaged
school or something,
and maybe that was the
first professional show
that they had seen.
And those days
especially, it feels
like you're there for
something bigger than yourself.
And I always feel like I have
my best shows those days,
because you're kind
of like, this is--
I mean, the tickets
are expensive.
And a lot of these
people would not
have a chance to see our show.
And that's a weird thing, I
think, for our cast anyways.
It's a weird thing to kind
of come to terms with,
that a lot of people who you
hope this show will reach
won't ever get the
chance to see it.
And then on those days,
it's like 2,300 people
who are like us a little
while ago, who are exactly us
a few years ago, having
the opportunity to share it
with them.
And so it feels so special.
I love #EduHam.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome
that you guys are doing that.
And I think Google-- when
you mentioned the companies--
Google is one of the ones that
sponsored one of the events,
so that's pretty cool that
we got to participate.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for a plug there.
So you guys are
doing these events
on top of your
normal show schedule.
Can you talk about--
you're doing eight shows some
weeks, two shows in a day?
I mean, first of
all, it just seems
like it would be physically
and mentally exhausting.
How do you get through
those kind of weeks?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Solea, you want to start?
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Sure,
I'll take a swing.
I think for all three of us--
this is the longest
show I've ever done.
So every time that we do a show,
I beat my own personal record
for how many shows I have done.
And it's a learning
curve, for sure.
When your body is your job,
you have to be really careful.
And it kind of just means
that there are certain things
that we don't get to do.
Like during the week, I don't
talk on the phone very often.
I don't Skype my friends
or talk to my mom.
I don't really
talk during the day
unless it's something
that I really want to do.
And I don't go out.
I don't drink.
It's just like things
like that, that are just
like little sacrifices,
especially when your voice is
your job.
I don't eat tomatoes
after 7:00, certain things
that you just have to
learn about yourself.
But it's a weird
thing to figure out,
because your lifestyle just
changes in such a huge way
once you're part of
a show like this.
Because eight shows
a week is serious,
and you don't want to miss it.
You don't want to not be
there for a million reasons.
But our job is weird
that way, in that
if our body isn't feeling 100%,
we can't do our jobs very well.
If we have a cold, it feels
like the end of the world,
and it sucks.
So a lot of vitamins,
a lot of B-12,
a lot of just eating lots of
veggies, and staying quiet.
And so there are times when
our job is so exciting,
but a lot of it is just chilling
out as much as possible.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Cool.
I have one more question,
but get your other questions
into the Dory and
then we're going
to do live questions after this.
So this one-- at Google,
representation and diversity--
it's really important to us.
And we talk about bring
your whole self to work.
And I think this is
something that "Hamilton" has
a lot of overlap with Google.
And from its initial
casting, it's
been very racially diverse.
I even was listening
to an interview
with Lin-Manuel
couple of days ago,
where he talked about how it
wouldn't surprise if there was
a woman cast as Alexander
Hamilton in the future, which
I think would be pretty cool.
So I was wondering what this
message that the show gives off
means to you guys personally?
And do you think that theater
has this special potential
to really drive this forward?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I
think that if the art is
willing to take that risk--
I mean, it's already
taking a risk
being art in the world where
so many things just die out,
or they get rejected, or
they're just not cool.
But if they take that risk
to be inclusive to everyone,
I think that's what makes
it special, especially
in a time like right now.
And one of the first things
I noticed when you all
walked in the room is that
everyone is just so diverse.
And it's just like,
this is a "Hamilton."
This is the world
that we live in.
And I think it's great that
"Hamilton" has given us
that platform to really show the
world that this is what America
looks like, and this is a
story, this is our history.
And being Latino, I think
that it's just exciting,
I'm very excited to
be an actor today
with all the inclusive
art coming to life.
I mean, there's awesome
shows on Netflix and Hulu,
and musicals with just people.
I mean, we're just all people.
So to see a show like "In
the Heights" seven years ago,
and to see Latinos on the
stage and dancing to salsa
and speaking Spanish, I'm
like that's me up there.
And now to be in
a show where I get
to be with my brothers
and sisters of color,
I'm in heaven.
And I get to tell an awesome
story that applies to me
and everyone around me.
So it's just an honor.
And I see this trend
continuing as long
as people take the
risk, and as long
as people are open to listen
to what everyone has to say.
I mean, the story
is important, yes.
But I think the way the story
is told is more important.
But yeah, I'm just excited.
I'm just blessed to be here.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah.
I mean, I actually heard
Lin addressing a crowd.
I was doing the show,
I was doing "Heights,"
and he was speaking
to the crowd.
And he was talking
about what made
him want to write at
all, let alone "Heights."
And it had something
to do with--
he had said, jokingly,
I don't dance.
And I'm not a dancer, and I was
never going to play Bernardo.
And then I also thought, I
don't know if I want to play--
in terms of Puerto Ricans
being represented in theater,
it's your "West Side Stories."
We're gang members,
we're the bad guys.
And that was just
not something he
saw doing once, or for a career,
or making a career out of.
So he was wondering
where was his opportunity
to show his best self?
And he didn't see it.
He couldn't find it, so
he wrote it, he made it,
which is amazing.
And then because
of that, similarly,
we've all had similar
experience in watching his work,
or any work where
we-- you have to,
in order to set your
sights on something,
or say that's something
that I could achieve,
sometimes it's helpful
to see it done first.
For me to see a Lin
go up, or for you
to see yourself on stage,
and say hey, that's me.
There's a home for me,
I see it, I want it,
I'm going to go
get it, you know?
And that's the coolest thing
about, I think, doing our show,
is that we are so diverse.
I think they always
say the casting
idea is supposed to look
like a New York City subway.
And that's great,
because it's inclusive,
and it allows these young
kids in these audience
that we see as
they're being touched,
and we see them directly seeing
themselves through a Raven,
or through a Julia,
or through a Solea,
and that's the coolest thing,
is we see ourselves in them.
And I think Solea said that
too, and that's the coolest part
about what we do.
And it's the core of
it, really, to reach out
to someone who might
not have known that they
can do anything, you know?
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: I
can say there's,
I feel, different levels to
think about this question.
And personally, this
show is the first time
that I didn't think about
my race when I auditioned.
I'm a mixed-race person,
and I'm constantly
being asked what are
you, like, duh, duh, duh.
And of course, I know I'm a
confusing person to look at,
and a lot of people, they're
like, well, are you Asian,
are you what?
I'm like, does it
matter, really?
And this was literally the first
role where I wasn't worried,
am I going to be able
to pass for this?
Will the fact that I
am this ambiguous--
does my type matter?
Does my skin tone matter?
It was the first time that I
was able to walk in and not
think about that.
It was just about what
I brought to the table,
and what I could do
with this material.
And as an actor,
there is nothing
more freeing than that at all.
And that felt like this huge
moment for me as an artist,
where I was like, there is
more to me than the way I look,
and I don't have to think
about that this time.
All I have to think about
is how amazing this is,
and I can look at these
lyrics and think about that,
rather than do I look
white enough for this?
Will I pass as black?
Will I pass as Asian,
duh, duh, duh--
these questions that are always
at the forefront of your mind
instead of the art.
And so I was able to put what
is actually important first,
and that felt amazing.
And I know when I saw this
show for the first time,
it was the first time that
I had seen myself on stage.
And that was one of the most
striking things about it.
I was just like, oh my god.
There's someone
who looks like me
who is the love interest here.
I was like, oh my god, there
are so many-- especially women
of color, I think, we
don't see ourselves as just
like the ingenue,
or the princess,
or the one to be coveted.
It doesn't happen a lot,
and it's an amazing feeling
when you see yourself.
And the idea--
I played Sandy once in "Grease."
[LAUGHTER]
And I remember thinking--
and I was brunette,
and it was a thing, kind of.
And I was like, wow, I can't
believe people actually
think about this.
But then taking that, and just
kind of-- when you really are
like, there's someone like me
in the audience who is seeing
themselves, maybe for the first
time, and seeing themselves,
that that is a
possibility for them--
that's so huge.
And then kind of on the
more grander scale of this,
there's this artist--
I hope I'm saying
his name correctly--
Kehinde Wiley, if anyone
has heard of him before.
He's this amazing--
check him out.
He's this artist, who'll
take old Renaissance photos,
or photos of our
founding fathers,
and he will take a
modern person of color,
and put them in their
place in the paintings.
And the idea is it's supposed to
challenge your idea of royalty,
challenge your idea
of intelligence,
and power in putting the person
of color in that position.
And it kind of
feels weird, and it
challenges your mind to think
differently about our history.
And I think that's exactly
what this show does.
And at first, it might be
jarring to someone's mind
or eye to see a black man
playing George Washington.
And I think people
at first, they
think it's maybe a bit of
a novelty or something.
I think people think
that it's part of--
I don't know-- like, ooh, that's
the thing that "Hamilton" does.
But after two minutes
of just watching it,
your mind just accepts it.
And you're like
yeah, you don't even
think twice that there's a black
man playing George Washington,
our first president.
And that is so huge.
I can't think of
anything, especially now--
I mean, especially always.
[LAUGHTER]
But as these things are really
at the forefront of our minds,
I just can't think of anything
more important, or anything
that can change the world
more than just people's core
values of how they
think about race,
and how they think about
power and intelligence.
And that we can
be a part of that
just by virtue of being
on stage and singing
these amazing songs, and
moving people, that we
can raise their consciousness.
And just because Lin was just
like, yeah, people of color
will be playing these roles.
That decision, I think,
was huge and imperative,
and I think it-- it makes me
feel so emotional, really.
Because it makes the world a
safer place and a better place.
And as we bring it
across the country,
I'm excited to see
how people continue
to have their consciousnesses
raised-- is that a word?
RYAN ALVARADO: It
sounds good to me.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks so much,
guys, for sharing that.
That was amazing.
So we're going to
transition to some
live Q&A. We also have
some Dory questions.
If you have a live question,
you can just put up your hand.
Brendan, are you
able to help with--
oh, we actually have
a microphone out there
that you can go up to.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: I was thinking
about that yesterday, actually.
We have some breaks
onstage, where
we're just sitting
on stage, and engage,
but we're not doing anything.
You'll see.
If you see the show, we're
around on stage a lot.
And I remember
thinking, the fact
that we are telling this
story through hip hop,
or rap or whatever,
the people who--
and a lot of the musical
themes that Lin used
are from Biggie songs, or
songs that already exist.
And a lot of people are going
to hear those, and be like, oh
my gosh, I know this song.
And one interesting thing
that I've always thought
is a funny juxtaposition
about this show
is that the people
who love Biggie
might not be the people who
are paying $1,500 to get
to see "Hamilton."
And what I think--
the fact that it is
told through this--
I think the people
who are, who are
going for a night
at the theater,
they are seeing hip
hop and rap maybe
for the first time for
them as a really valid form
of expression.
Because, for a lot of
people, they don't even
bother to listen to
this type of music,
or they have a certain
stigma attached to their mind
about what it means, and
what their message is.
It's always been a valid
form of expression.
But for a lot of people,
this might be the first time
that they're seeing a
story that they know,
and it's told through
a different way,
and they're still moved,
and they're still affected,
and they still
understand the story.
But they are being challenged
to actually see it and listen,
and have it be through
a form of expression
and they may not have been
comfortable with before.
And I think that is just
as important as the casting
and everything else.
I don't know if this is
answering your question.
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, I think that is one
of the other important layers
of this, that this is not
necessarily a type of music.
And now, it's just
so mainstream.
People are having their
kids listen to it.
And I think that's a
new phenomenon, kind of.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: How is
your version different
from the original
Broadway version?
And what additions,
changes, or new spins
does your cast put on the show?
Do you guys have the liberties
to do stuff like that?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: You play Ham,
so you should talk about that.
You play Lin's character.
RYAN ALVARADO: In terms of the
show as a whole big picture,
it's "Hamilton."
That's what the goal is, to
bring you something that's
on Broadway, so that we can tour
it, and share this amazing show
with as many people as possible.
But in terms of the direction
of it, and how we're taught it,
and how the information
is given to us,
there's many
parameters, as there
are with any Broadway show.
There's hit this mark.
It all comes down to math,
and spacing, and gridding,
and you're on six by this green
box, and duh, duh, duh, duh.
And there's so much of that.
But they make sure,
especially with this piece,
to let you know where
you need to fill in,
where you need to
put yourself here.
The direction is
to go through this.
There's a song-- if
we're all familiar--
"Quiet Uptown," where
we lose our son.
And it's kind of like that.
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, that, to
me, we don't get
noted a bunch on it, because
the main direction there
is to do your best
to live through that,
to really try to fight through
that, and get through that,
and understand that,
and cope with it,
and communicate that to our
fellow castmates on stage,
and as well, to get it to
jump off the stage to you.
So as long as that's
the parameter for it,
is really do your best
to go all the way there.
And Solea does it
every single night.
And it's one of the
more difficult things
to do in the show.
But that's what
that moment needs.
So it's more about that
in terms of like giving
the moment what it needs.
And in order to do that, I might
need to do it a different way
than Lin went about it.
Or Ruben is going to have
to do it a different way
than Anthony Ramos
did it, you know?
And that's OK.
And we're definitely
pushed in that way,
where we're invited to
explore, to investigate, to try
new things.
And we always have an
amazing team of directors,
of choreographers that live with
our company as well out here
in San Francisco.
So we always have
someone to touch base
with that is probably more
connected to that original
production, or that
original vision than we are,
so that we can figure out how
we're going to go about this,
and be able to provide
whoever's watching it
with the best
"Hamilton" experience
that we can as people.
Because we'll never be them.
And that's what's meant to be.
It's really supposed
to keep passing
on to the next group
and the next group,
so we can hand this message
off to the next generation,
you know?
SPEAKER 1: Great.
Can we go to a live question?
AUDIENCE: With seven
or eight shows a week,
kind of doing the same
thing over and over again
every night, how do
you keep it fresh?
How do you bring energy
every single night?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I
think, at least for myself,
the first three months of
doing the show were just
like a whirlwind.
I was still like, oh
my gosh, I'm nervous,
I've got to hit this mark.
So I was going through
that every single show.
And I think eventually, I
not only got comfortable
with the show, but also
just kind of told myself
that this is unique to me.
I don't really have to
pretend to be anybody else.
I don't have to please--
I mean, I have to
please my directors.
But I'm saying I don't
have to tailor my show,
because in doing that,
I'm damaging my process,
and getting in my head.
But to answer your
question more specifically,
it's finding new
moments, and finding
where you can still build.
And so our jobs are
never done as actors.
So just because
we've set the show
doesn't mean that we can
just glide through it.
I mean, there's still
that emotional connection
to the show.
And it's a show that I
care very deeply about,
so obviously, I'm
going to put everything
I have into the show.
And it's a different show
every night, it really is.
Things go wrong.
Things don't happen how they're
supposed to, or things change.
And it's part of our jobs
as actors to adapt to that.
And it's the jobs
of the creative team
that's here in San Francisco to
keep us on our toes about that.
So if I try something--
not necessarily new--
but try something
different, maybe my director
says, OK, that's
cool, work with that.
Or maybe don't do
that ever again.
[LAUGHTER]
But we're still--
it's a growing,
it's a breathing thing.
And so we're always
finding new ways
to approach the same moments.
And it also helps that
our company is very tight.
And we always have new people
coming into the show that
are in the company.
So the swings will go on, or
the understudies will go on.
And those are some
of my favorite shows,
is just seeing how a new
person takes the role,
and how they put
themselves into that role.
So at times, it can
get sort of monotonous,
I guess, maybe for
lack of a better word.
But it's still so much fun.
I still wouldn't trade
this for anything.
It's just-- yeah.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: I can
speak to this a little.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: I know I
thought that it would start
to feel really difficult to
do the exact same thing over
and over and over again.
And I think it can.
I have done shows where I
became incredibly bored of it
pretty quickly.
And to my shock, quite
frankly, this show,
I'm not even close
to satisfied with it.
And I don't think
I will ever be.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh god.
Oh no.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
We're brand ambassadors.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Right?
Oh, god.
But what I mean, this show
is such a gift to the actors.
There's something to be
mined from it every time.
The relevance of
the show literally
changes with the news
of the world that day.
You will find new
relevance to something,
and find a new way
to connect with it,
depending on the
biggest headline,
or whatever happened
to you personally.
And I don't think there's a lot
of shows that are like that.
And so Lin really
created a show that
is such a gift to the actor
in that there is something
new to find every time.
And people always
tell us, we found out
we got these tickets
a year ago, or these
were my birthday present, or my
anniversary present, duh, duh,
duh, duh.
And so people have had this
date circled on their calendar
for a really long time.
And it is our duty to make it
as perfect as an experience
as we can, if nothing else.
We work four hours a day.
So I should be able to put
my entire self into this,
because 2,300 people showed
up, and are so excited,
and are expected to be moved.
And damn right, they should be.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's really our duty.
It's what I went to
college for, so I could
be as good at this as possible.
And so yeah, you
really assume, even
on days when you're
kind of feeling down,
or low, or whatever, as
soon as you step on stage
and he'll go, Alexander
Hamilton, I feel like, ahh!
[LAUGHTER]
And you're like,
OK, all right, yes.
I love my job, and
I'm lucky to be here,
and that moment, always, I'm
just like, OK, all right,
here we go.
Do you have any--
RYAN ALVARADO: Oh no.
SPEAKER 1: It's great to
hear that you guys are still
enjoying it, and not bored.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yes.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: But if
you were bored,
this brings us to
our next question.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: From Sonny
F. Given the opportunity
to play any other character
from the show other than the one
or ones that you currently
play, what would it be and why?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Peggy.
[LAUGHTER]
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Peggy?
RYAN ALVARADO: Why not?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
Why not, right?
RYAN ALVARADO: Because why not?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: No, I
mean, I'm only half kidding.
I mean, like--
[LAUGHTER]
It's so-- I mean--
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Peggy's fun.
Peggy's fun.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Peggy's cool.
SOLEA PFEIFFER:
It's totally valid.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: She's cool.
I would love to play
Hercules Mulligan.
That role is just so fun.
Yeah, it just like--
all his lines are just
like, bro, bro, like,
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
Like, I'm totally not that,
but that's being an actor.
Like, I want to do
that one day maybe.
SOLEA PFEIFFER:
Yeah, I have thought
about this in deep depths.
I've really thought
about this question,
because I used to think
it was Burr, because Burr
has some fierce moments.
RYAN ALVARADO: Right.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: And if you guys
have seen Joshua Henry do it,
you understand why anyone
would want to play Burr.
So he's incredible, and
it's an amazing role.
But one thing-- at least
for women in theater--
I have never played a role
where almost every song I sang
was not about the
male protagonist.
And female characters
usually start
to exist as soon as the male
character is like, hey, I would
love to have a girlfriend.
And then she appears, and
they sing together, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
And "Hamilton" is
kind of that way too.
Eliza-- I sing exclusively about
my man, and it's his story,
it's "Hamilton," you know.
But that has been my experience
pretty much exclusively
as an actress, is the songs
that I sing are about the boy.
And Burr is kind
of like that too.
Burr is kind of written
like a female character.
[LAUGHTER]
He is, and it's an amazing role,
but he talks about Hamilton
the whole time too.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN ALVARADO: He's mine.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah, literally.
[APPLAUSE]
And so when I really thought
about it-- oh my god,
to be able to play
a character that
sings about their own thoughts
and feelings and wants in life,
and goals would be the
most amazing thing.
And so if I ever got the
chance to play Hamilton,
I would take that chance.
I would love it.
[CHEERING]
RYAN ALVARADO:
And I would watch.
She's great.
Me, I would say--
I cover a few roles.
I cover Hamilton,
and I cover Burr,
so that's like memorizing
the dictionary on it itself.
[LAUGHTER]
But for me, I actually wouldn't
mind doing Lafayette Jefferson,
just because I think it's
another thing where it's very
wordy, it's a very rappy role.
But I would even put it
in terms of just the rap
craft of that role is probably
the biggest challenge that you
can take on, I think, in
terms of being a wordsmith.
And I love
challenges, and I that
would be probably the next one.
Yeah?
SPEAKER 1: Can we go
for a live question?
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks for coming today.
I'm curious about the
journeys you each take
as actors from that moment
when as kids or teenagers,
the theater bug
hit, you said, I've
got to be in musical
theater, this
is what I'm going to go for,
the educations you went through,
the training to be
able to get in the most
famous musical in ages.
For each of you, what were
some of the paths you took,
and what do you think were
some of the key factors that
let you get to where you are?
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Should I start?
RYAN ALVARADO: Please.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: I was
a huge summer camp kid.
I feel like I owe my
decision to choose
this life to summer camp.
Because I played
violin very early on.
My parents were love the arts.
They were always
super supportive,
whatever I wanted to do.
But I remember when I went
to a theater summer camp
for the first time, that
was when I was like,
oh my god, these are my people.
And this is what
makes me feel alive.
And I was young, but
that never stopped.
That bug really did catch
on pretty early for me.
I feel like was like, eight.
I played Peter Pan
in a 15-minute skit
that we wrote at the
camp, but I loved it.
I always loved it.
I went back every year,
and I continued to do it.
I did it in middle
school, and then I
went to a really serious
high school, where they
had an amazing drama program.
And then when I found out that
I could do this in college,
I was kind of like,
oh my god, if I
could continue to study
this, there's nothing better.
My parents were very much like,
you're going to go to college.
My parents are
college professors,
and they're like, that
is the next step for you.
Study whatever you
want, but get a degree,
because no one can take
that away from you.
And that has carried me on.
I'm really glad
that I went through.
Some people leave school
early, this and that.
But yeah, going to college
and studying it for four--
I went to the
University of Michigan.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, hey, go Blue?
[LAUGHTER]
We're everywhere.
I meet Wolverines everywhere.
Yeah, I went to the
University of Michigan.
I got a BFA in musical theater.
There's about 80 of us
in the whole program.
It's a small program
in a huge university.
And there wasn't a
better program for me
to go to, personally.
I had the best time
there, and kind of
figured out what kind of
artist I wanted to be,
what kind of work
I wanted to do.
Because I think a
lot of people have
an idea of what a musical
theater person is,
and they're probably
pretty right.
[LAUGHTER]
But in terms of
who I wanted to be,
and what path I want
to forge for myself,
I [INAUDIBLE] I studied
in London for four months,
doing Shakespeare only,
not even touching anything
musical theater-related.
And I think that changed
how I approach everything.
And I was actually
still in school
when I sent in an audition
tape for this show.
I had listened to
the soundtrack,
and I was like,
oh my gosh, I have
to be a part of this somehow.
And so I sent an audition
tape maybe a month
before I graduated.
Then I came back, did a few more
auditions after I graduated.
And it was actually the first
job that I got post school.
[LAUGHTER]
And so it was--
[APPLAUSE]
And it was one of
those ridiculous--
where the stars just
aligned, and it really
was the perfect role.
It was one of those
weird things, where
in school, everyone's like,
this would be perfect for you,
and you're like, oh whatever.
And then it happened,
and you're like, whoa.
But yeah, I think an
important thing for any kids,
or anyone who has kids who
might want to pursue this,
is really learning
about yourself a lot,
because nothing will inform
your craft more than knowing who
you are.
And I'm really happy
that I took the time
to find out who I was, and
travel, and do things that
weren't focused specifically
on our industry,
and just learning how to do a
triple pirouette or something,
or being fierce.
Because there's a
lot of fierce people,
but there aren't a
lot of genuine people,
I think, in what we do.
And I think nothing
reads more, and nothing
is more moving to an audience
than a genuine performance,
or someone who really
knows who they are.
And that's something that you
can really feel and sense.
And so University of Michigan
kind of allowed me to do that.
I was able to take classes on
witchcraft, and random things,
and figure out who I was, rather
than just like dance class,
dance class only, and you know.
And yeah, nothing makes a better
artist than a well-read person,
I guess, if that
makes any sense.
RYAN ALVARADO: For sure.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: So yeah,
I owe all my journey
to summer camp, and teachers,
and supportive parents,
and kind of allowing
myself room to figure out
who I was, and really
decide that I really
wanted to do this.
This is kind of unrelated--
my senior year,
I found out I had
a thyroid nodule on my throat.
And I have a scar
right here, and I've
had surgery on my throat
my senior year of college.
And I was like, oh my god,
of all the places on my body,
the most important one?
I was like, I wish this
could have been-- you know.
And I was freaking out,
and it was this huge kind
of like come to Jesus
moment for me, because I
realized that there's nothing
else that I want to do more.
I was kind of like, if something
goes wrong, I don't know.
And when everything was OK, it
was kind of this moment of OK,
guard this with your life.
Guard this future.
I realized there's
nothing else that
was going to make
me quite as happy,
and it lit this
fire underneath me.
And I was like, OK,
now you're going
to make this happen, because
you know this is what you want.
And it was one of
those moments that
was horrible in the moment, but
I learned so much about myself.
And I learned that this
was the life that I wanted.
And so I'm really grateful.
But it was an important
part of my journey,
which is why I added it.
But yeah, yeah.
That's me.
RYAN ALVARADO: Oh yeah.
No, amazing.
I guess-- I don't know if I
consider myself a late bloomer,
but I did it in middle school,
just did the school play
in middle school.
But I also did the shows
in high school and stuff,
and that's when I got serious.
I started thinking about it
as a job, or a possible job.
Definitely something that I was
really taken by, and intrigued
by, so I got serious.
In my own head, I just clicked
that light switch, where
I think everyone does that.
They just say, I'm this,
this is part of me now, yes.
Because it's just
that kind of thing.
It's an it's an artistic path.
So I started that mentally.
I went to school.
I was actually cut
from my program.
I went to a small school.
It was an acting program
just 30 minutes north
of the city, SUNY Purchase.
It was a great little
acting program.
And then this inner fire is kind
of what's propelled me forward,
and that's through rejection,
through all these things
that I felt were in my way.
I at least have been the
type of person, I think,
that I've always
wanted to overcome.
I've always wanted
to surpass people
who might have tried
to put me in this box,
or say maybe the no for this.
If I say yes, it's yes.
I can go do that, you know?
So when I left
school, I didn't stop.
That was when I got literally,
like everything was just--
not them specifically,
but even your family,
you'll find that you have
naysayers at a young age.
They'll be like no, they act
out, but that's impossible,
that's the hardest career.
It's so hard to do, and it is.
I just knew I would
do it, I would try.
I would give my all, and I did.
And after college, I
got my first company job
at a year-round theater.
They hired me out for a
couple of years of work,
and I treated that as kind of
like the complementary thing
to my education.
And I've done it.
And it also helped me build
who I was as a person,
because I learned
in that experience,
I decided that I would
finish school in my head
by making everyone around
me my teacher, right?
It's like, the star of the
show, or whoever it is,
or the director, or anyone
who I valued something
that they had to gain.
Because you learn in acting
too, like a great way to learn--
it's not bad in the world
of acting-- but stealing,
you know?
Seeing something that, oh
wow, and I want to wear that,
or I want to put
it on, or I want
to figure out how to also take
those skills and apply them.
Maybe we all do
this, I don't know.
But I just started doing that.
I started compartmentalizing
who were my professors for what
I was going to take, or
by the end of this show,
I want to be able
to do that, or I
want to be able to dance
like that, or whatever it is.
And I just started
going day by day,
trying to figure out till I
could graduate in my head.
And then this theater that I
worked at was on Long Island.
This place, where it was was
like an hour east of the city.
I gathered as much as I
could, and then I packed up,
I moved into the
city, and I started
gigging and auditioning.
And I've never left that
mentality, though I do it now.
Because you know this
is a great opportunity,
but they tell you
when you get here,
obviously, it's always
eyes on the prize.
What's next?
What can we turn this into?
And the only way
that I'll get there
is by learning
from everyone here,
everyone that we
work with, everyone
we've been blessed to meet
along on this journey.
You all, you know?
It helped me figure out
how I wanted to work,
or what type of artist that
I wanted to be as well.
And that was my journey.
And I compartmentalize rejection
that way, and nos, and doubts.
Instead of let them hinder me,
I tend I try to use them always,
whether it's prove
someone wrong,
the chip on the shoulder.
Might not be the best
way, but you know.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: It works.
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah, it
worked for me, you know?
But yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Cool.
SPEAKER 1: Can we take
one last live question?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I feel like I'm
cutting off your journey.
[LAUGHTER]
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Mine?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Oh.
I mean, I went to
school, graduated.
I got a BFA in 2015.
I owe it all to my mom.
She put me in theater
when I was a kid.
I didn't want to do it,
but then she like kept--
[LAUGHTER]
She was like, hey,
do this, do that.
And I did some TV
commercial stuff
when I was a kid, so
I knew I liked it.
Once I started to get into it,
I knew I really enjoyed it.
But yeah, the flame
was lit in high school.
And since then, I never stopped.
I'm just like, go, go, go.
And if somebody tells
me no, I'm like, well,
I'm going to go around
that, and keep going.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: So one of
the things that I
love about "Hamilton" in
that it's sung through
is that the breadth
of songs is huge,
so you can kind of
discover different things.
And when I first
started listening,
I gravitated towards the
biggies, like "Wait For It,"
and "It's Quiet Uptown."
But now for some
reason, I can't stop
listening to "We Know" and
"The Reynolds Pamphlet" back
to back, just over
and over again.
So I was wondering
if there's songs
that you guys love
that you don't sing,
that are not part of your
role, that in the first act
and second act that you just
gravitate towards right now?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Second
act, I can tell you that--
well, my favorite
song in "Hamilton"
is "The Room Where it Happens."
and I owe a lot of that to
Josh Henry, who plays Burr.
I'm lucky enough to be
onstage while he's performing
that number, and I'm just
doing my little choreography
here while he's giving this
award-winning performance.
But just to see his
transformation is so awesome.
I mean, to see him how he is
before that song to after,
he turns into a monster.
Like he just looks
taller, and looks meaner,
and he's ready to
go kill someone.
I mean, he does, but--
[LAUGHTER]
I just--
RYAN ALVARADO: Spoiler alert.
[LAUGHTER]
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Just like
that song, just by itself,
without the acting part of
it, just how it's written,
it just gets me.
It's just so good.
And yeah, I'm just lucky
enough to be on stage with him
while he's doing that.
I really like "Satisfied."
And I remember the first
time I saw "Satisfied--"
SOLEA PFEIFFER: (WHISPERING)
Oh, it's so good.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
I liked every song.
"Satisfied" wasn't my
favorite when I first
listened to the recording.
But when I saw it, and I
saw how they staged it,
I was just like,
what is going on?
Why are they playing with
my emotions like that?
[LAUGHTER]
I was just so
happy and helpless,
like, yeah, I'm helpless.
[LAUGHTER]
They're like--
SPEAKER 1: Rewind.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL:
--kissing, and marriage,
and then all of a sudden,
you just get hit in the face,
and you're like,
what, [SPUTTERING]
and then it was over.
So yeah, those two are
probably my favorite songs
that I don't sing in.
But yeah.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah.
I guess like, singing it--
but I love "Non-stop."
"Non-stop" has been my
favorite in act one, always,
just from jump.
Mostly because you
can just geek out
at how the musical
themes that Lin
took, and devoted each character
to, when they come together,
it's musical theory heaven.
You can just geek out so
hard over that moment, even
just looking at the sheet music,
and realizing what they did
in terms of how they were
going to take one musical idea
and use it to tell
the story, and use
those little themes to define
who those characters are.
And when they all come together,
it just is the coolest thing.
So you're like, I
recognize that, I recognize
that, I recognize that.
And I think the amazing
thing about music theory,
and Alex Lacamoire being the
most amazing musical arranger--
I don't know the exact wording.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Orchestrator.
SOLEA PFEIFFER:
Orchestrator, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
When you have all these musical
geniuses all on the same page,
working to just tell the
story so specifically and so
perfectly, that song is
an amazing combination
of all those things
coming together.
Because the musical--
I don't know.
I just love to geek out
on the music theory stuff.
And I love "Obedient Servant."
I just think it's so good.
I think it's so good.
RYAN ALVARADO: It
is, it is a good jam.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: It's so good.
You're just like, hey.
And I just get to listen
to that one backstage.
I'm the only person
backstage during that part.
You too?
Where are you?
We got to hang out.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't know this.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I'm
not right backstage.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Where
have you been hiding?
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: I'm
in my dressing room.
SOLEA PFEIFFER:
Oh my god, well, I
can always see-- my boyfriend
is actually in the show.
We met in college, and now
we're both in "Hamilton."
He's going to be Hamilton
tonight, actually.
RUBEN J. CARBAJAL: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Yeah.
We're going to be
opposite each other.
But I always--
during that number,
because I have all this free
time, and he's right offstage,
I can always mess with him.
I'm like, hey, boo.
[LAUGHTER]
I always try to make him
laugh, he never does.
I always get to mess with him
there, so that's another part.
That's another reason
why it's my favorite.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN ALVARADO: Yeah.
A song that I don't do--
I can only think of "Burn."
OK, so "Hamilton,"
it this huge show.
I'm sure we've all seen it.
There's so many moving pieces.
We've got turntables going,
we've got so many lights.
We've got all these mic
cues, all these costumes,
all these changes.
And it really is
an ginormous thing.
But to me, it reminds you
of what brought you there,
what we're doing it
for, when you just
see an actress, an amazing
one like Solea-- we have
many covers also,
that are all doing
this in their different way.
But it's that kind
of thing in our show
where you're being hit
with so much stimulus,
and then a song like
"Burn" comes on,
and it's all taken away.
It's one person,
in one light cue,
and she's got one thing to say.
And she's going to
use all this music,
and all this song to do it in.
But I think it's one
of the hardest things
that anyone does in
our show, and they're
doing it every single day.
And like we said earlier, every
show is that show for you.
So I see her angle
into the song change.
And when different people
do it, their entire approach
may be different.
I've seen her end in a
different-- or heard,
I have to hide in
the back during that.
But I've heard it
end a different place
than it might have.
And the calibration of
that specific journey
without a scene partner,
without all the things
that make "Hamilton"
"Hamilton" to me
is one of the craziest
feats you can do.
And I don't know how often
it happens in the show,
but that's definitely the
biggest one, where it's just
go, you know?
Make them cry, or
whatever it is.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's wildly impressive.
I've told her many
a time, and all
the girls who do it, it's
one of the single most
difficult things,
I think, an actor
or actress who is doing in the
contemporary musical theater
in any show, you know?
So that impresses me without
fail every single show,
every single day.
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Awesome.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you guys
so much for joining us.
Let's put our hands together
for the cast of "Hamilton."
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
SOLEA PFEIFFER: Thanks, guys.